[Music]
how is this different for men and women
well you've been working women for a
decade for years yeah so i think that or
is there a difference well i don't know
i mean all of its all of my
thoughts on that are more just kind of
uh you know gut intuition but i have
noticed a trend where i hear women say
i'm failing and i don't hear men say
that in that same way not from the same
place of like i'm failing as a dad i'm
failing at work i'm just failing
everywhere whereas women say that and
they say it and they reinforce it and
they all say it to each other that no
you're not no i am but you're not i mean
this narrative that they're failing
haunts them
i do think that um at least at least in
my observations you can tell me if you
feel like this but i think that
men tend to
compartmentalize easier like matt seems
to be able to compartmentalize a little
bit easier whereas when he's at work i
don't i really don't think he's thinking
about us which is awesome gotcha because
he's at work be where your feet are
the more i've tried to practice that the
more balanced i feel where i can
actually be present the moment that i'm
in but i feel like women are often like
our mind is in a million places and
often it's in the places that we're not
so then we feel guilty so i don't know i
mean do you feel like you can compare
several questions to that um
um
i'm taking notes here industry um
so
i used to until i read terence real's
work about overt and covert depression
meaning
um you look at the stats it looks like
on on its face that women experience
depression they experience these seasons
of guilt this i'm i'm a failure
way more than men and what he came out
and said that's absolutely inaccurate
men
have demonstrate depression by puffing
their chest out oh god
by doing by yelling by
numbing
and so where
a man may not men may not put it out
there to the world they may not
verbalize i'm failing they'll go have
nine drinks and disappear in front of a
ball game they'll go golf all day all
day all they'll go hide
and um so it ends up being the same
thing they just they have different
words for it yeah and so there i it may
not be as identity driven my identity
might not drive me to the ground yeah
but they are killing themselves just the
same well when i have given this talk
and this content i've been speaking on
this topic to
our entree leadership audiences from
summit to master series whatever since
2013 so a really long time different
iterations of it
um and even back in the day years ago it
used to be much more male uh audience
it hit a nerve yep big time yep and so
there's something about it that we all
there's something in us that we feel
like there
there's something more for us that we
need something not to do more not to run
harder and faster but like something
feels like it's not right and i want to
fix that feeling and i don't know what
that is and that's
i think that we describe it with balance
i need more work-life balance well you
could take a vacation you can take time
off you can leave at five
but if you still have that narrative
that you're failing then it doesn't
matter what time you leave work because
you're taking that narrative home with
you and you're bringing it to work with
you the next day you say this all the
time like wherever you go next you're
taking you with you right and if that
story is a story you believe and nurture
and fuel and accept and and live out of
well then the story is what we have to
fix the that idea not just the calendar
the one of the things i said the other
day that i thought oh gosh that
summarizes it so well
this is not a calendar issue it's not
just about the calendar it's about
enjoying the life that the calendar
represents i want to help people do that
so how do you help somebody or
it
when i used to travel with with work and
now we travel now i used to
as soon as i'd get on a plane
i'd start writing notes to my kids i
would text my wife i would
start trying to anchor back to where i
was because i was guilty that i was
leaving she with two little kids i was
guilty i was going to get to stay in a
hotel by myself and sleep and all those
things
and it occurred to me a couple years ago
oh i'm dishonoring whatever group i'm
going to speak to i am
not helping them at home at all i am
making a choice to be more miserable by
trying to be having my heart
back there my work over here
so now when i leave the house i'm out i
am focused on where i'm headed yeah it
feels like there's an industry there's
an ecosystem there's there's air and
water that we breathe and swim in
directed towards women to make sure
you're never where you are
does that make sense there's an industry
of guilt that is surrounds women in a
way that i don't feel yeah yeah you
should be at home with your kids and if
you're not why are you at home with your
kids we worked all this time you should
be a vice president of a company if
you're vice president of a company you
should be wearing this does that make
sense okay i'm not gonna get into the
whole gender thing with this but i am
curious when you travel do people ask
you who's watching the kids they do with
me they do yes but i yes like where are
your kids where's your family yes and i
know who's watching the kids
um
no the assumption is just my wife is 100
yeah i get asked everywhere i go who's
watching the kids uh i don't know the
dog i don't know i just hope they'd work
out like matt never gets asked that
that's never been asked in his whole
stinking life who's watching the kids
i'm like isn't that fascinating there
there i think there is something just
the assumption right 100 yeah i think
sometimes it's spoken sometimes it's
unspoken and i'm not mad about i love
being a mom like i love that people you
know that's great but i do think that
there is pressure there and i will tell
you that that is years ago i discovered
that's where so much my guilt came from
was always focused on where i was not so
when i'm at work i'm thinking about my
kids oh are they okay or they you know
did i forget this that are they sick do
they need me then i would go home and
i'd be with them and i'm checking email
and i forgot to write to finish that
chapter and you know got to respond to
that
so if you are always focused on where
you are not
then of course you feel guilty because
you're always focused on where you're
not and by the way you also are
completely missing the moment that
you're in so the
analogy i use as a is a car
flip your focus instead of always
looking through the rear view mirror of
what you're leaving behind look through
the front windshield of where you're
going
and be where you feed where your feet
are so i'm just like you when i walk out
the door by i intentionally
channel my focus to what i'm going to
yep and then when i go home same thing
it's like i'm shutting this off as much
as i possibly can it it allows you to
not just be more present it allows you
to experience and enjoy those moments
more because you're actually in them now
and by the way you don't feel guilty
because you're like no i'm focused on
the thing i'm doing look i'm doing great
now i'm gonna go home and be doing great
then versus i didn't do that i didn't do
that i'm leaving that behind you know